I got home yesterday and kiss was like
you're not gonna believe what happened
to day in the news and today is I don't
know Oh Trump
no no we'll talk about that later dude
and that's every day in the news yes
every day a new truth oh no what was
that oh there's multiple Trump's you're
right
okay and this is okay so I have a video
clip we'll watch it kind of just is
self-explanatory we can talk all about
it but this umbrella man no oh oh my god
this was just very go [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
nuts
oh why people have been out on the
streets protesting why this violence is
taking place there is some action behind
you
yep you've got one person being arrested
here this is the Minneapolis they met us
here they had us here we're speaking
with State Patrol right now give us a
second guys we can move back to where
you'd like you can move back to where
you'd like here we are live on the air
at the moment this is the four of us we
are one team put us back where you want
us we were getting out of your way so
corridors let us know where we will go
we were just getting out here the
anchors the black guy with the face mask
but I'm sorry okay so they arrested the
anchor yeah yes for what because the
good look apparently like what the [ __ ]
are they thinking they're like let's get
[ __ ] coming it's not like a telephone
camera it's a [ __ ] big at CNN camera
wait just him the camera guy did not get
arrested well he says it's a team of
four what about that other white guy
there
our CNN producers what happened to
freedom of the press
exactly so this the camera guy he's been
arrested never seen this before well
actually I have I've seen something like
this he's putting you down so the whole
camera crew got arrested yesterday in
the morning what's better than having
the only black guy you arrested true
yeah well I was watching it I had price
at this point though yeah but then but
then they weren't citizens you know like
they had they had their badge out they
were even saying it they're very
culturally especially the the black news
anchor guy right he was here just like
we had here holding he was like hold on
hold on saying like hey let me get the
my pass out my badge out and then and
then he was like we can move wherever
you guys want said multiple times and
like you don't hear the cops was
extremely compliant yeah and he was very
composed to like wasn't like outraged
right it's been in situation like this
where it's all Kate is still [ __ ]
right and he's like yeah and he's just
reporting the news and he's in other
moments where I cut out the because it's
just such a long clip but I cut it out
but you can hear them saying like hey
we're just trying to like report what
you guys want like you know you guys are
trying to Spurs the riots you're trying
to like calm everything down and then
you know so we're trying to tell your
story and like cops aren't telling like
telling [ __ ] like they're gonna say
anything at all other than you're under
arrest and then they're like why you
arresting us and they see nothing I will
say that is it legal it's weird
there weren't so much gear I doubt they
could even hear him I mean Jesus Christ
you sure you haven't just reading them
around under the Miranda rights B's
can't hear I did I did do some research
and like the amount of training it takes
to become a police officer drastically
varies from state to state oh really
there's no standardized weeks and then
or some of them are like like LAPD is
six months some of them are like in two
weeks it's it they're all different wait
you could you could finish the police
academy in two weeks some up in some
states yeah yeah well I have a friend
who's a volunteer policeman but he um
what does that mean so he
to go to the Academy right but okay so
some states or something some talents -
they need volunteer policemen yes Steven
Seagal something quite like Steven
Seagal there's areas in like New Mexico
Arizona and there's little towns by the
border and all over America where maybe
it's population of like 300 or whatever
and not everyone can be a cop right and
that town can't afford like paying a cop
so yeah so what what what ends up
happening is like let's say you
volunteer your services as a part-time
cop and in some people they'll go into
town and then they'll do their service
like X amount of times a month or
whatever and some people they're like
either retired cops or they have some
type of training or like my friend
specifically he's a he trains like
military and law enforcement a lot of
like how to shoot and all those things
so he does his I just duty by like
giving and he's like some of these towns
like you wouldn't even realize that this
is still America because they're just at
the brink of like kind of like the
cartel coming in and running it over
okay take them taken over yeah but
people don't know how dangerous it is
it's like you just see this little
desert town and in and then you think
it's like oh they just do nothing out
there but like the cartels in there and
are like we'll kill everybody here and
they're like we don't have enough cops
to help this whole place yeah and I'm
like that's crazy yeah well that's not
the case from Minneapolis they have the
State Police there and they're arresting
journalists so a little more about this
so they were detained for about an hour
and then in that hour the the black dude
that got arrested he was saying like
there were a few uneasy moments but they
were okay they were treated cordially
and and then after an hour they they
were able to clarify with CNN and also
the mayor of Minneapolis that they are
indeed journalists even though they had
the [ __ ] you know that's weird
and so they had to like verify it
through higher-ups too and then they
they were let go so nothing really they
even explain why they were detained
though is it because like they're in the
middle of like riding and they were
about to move in there in the wet like I
don't get but I thought either way there
when it came to press and journalism
they were almost like medics and war
where they're immune to a neutral I can
annotate they're there to tell us they
said to tell I'm like okay you guys got
to be over here or whatever yeah and
that's what there's a lot of people are
saying like a lot of analysts are saying
like they should just really create a
space for their journalist name this is
happening because that's not cool and
like and like from the way the video
played out it seemed like the cops are
just moving a lot faster and movement
for the news crew to really react to and
they kind of got caught up in the middle
of it and circled some circle money
because it like it you see the beginning
like they're arresting a citizen that
the girl that was there and so in they
were just they just happen to be really
close by and they're like you guys got
to go to that's all they had to say even
like it's like he understood the
protocol because like hey just let us
know we're we're out of your way and
we're good exactly and so and now
another analyst was saying like how you
know for those people that say you know
the way you treat cops you know like you
know if you're ever you know there's a
problem getting pulled over or whatever
just comply just comply right and you
can get out so you saying like well this
is a perfect counterpoint to that like
just complying he's not he would have
been under right you're still under
arrest so like it's just [ __ ] there's
really no answer as to why that happened
and another CNN anchor that was around
the block another news crew who happened
to be a white anchor a white reporter
right he he said he showed badges his
little lanyard thing and he was like
yeah I didn't get any problems what did
they think the [ __ ] camera had like a
[ __ ] missile and they're ready to
shoot it like it's a deep maybe maybe
they made a mistake by like a resting
like the black anchor first and be like
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] we gotta cover it up
just get everybody out the white guys
I'm so sorry I gotta do this arrest the
kid get the kid get everybody get
everybody see we're not racist we're
doing everybody here everybody that's
triggered is the black guy the black guy
is actually half black and half Latino
his name is Omar Jimenez and then the
camera guy was Hispanic and then there's
the producer that was white so got more
and more light skin as they exactly they
worked their way through the color
spectrum they did the black guy first
and then they went lighter yeah is a
mess right it's a mess but it matches
Minneapolis because just last night
right before I was like I think I found
all my articles they came across another
video and this bogged on New York is
horrible right this happened to another
journalist oh [ __ ]
or is this at Kentucky Kentucky but he's
shooting at the journalists yeah
white female what is happening
point-blank range dude did you oh my god
yeah that's [ __ ] up dude [ __ ] crazy
you're just like hey get away from us
you didn't even care he's on camera dude
yeah Kentucky so it's not just
Minneapolis that's like [ __ ] Barney's
ya know New York to like any protester
as the cars are driving away like cop
cars they'll just open the car just to
hit people and they're not even in the
way like they're going out of their way
to hit people like another New York
officer was walking one way and there
was a protester and he just grabbed her
and he chucked her like it's [ __ ]
nuts right now it is you think like all
the cops are like under the blue veil
are they just [ __ ] pissed right now
when they're like just
every weekend so it's super complicated
because I follow a bunch of cops too and
there's a lot of cops like talking [ __ ]
about the cops with stupid behavior
right now all cops are the same no
there's a lot of cops that I like - I
can't believe they even did that to
George Floyd that's like cuz i III
watched them like argue in the comments
and then one of them was saying like if
you are a police officer and you first
get there and if this guy is under a
medal if you indeed it was under medical
condition you are first a life saver so
you're you you think about that first
you're kind of going to EMT mode before
you go into law mode so you're just kind
of breaking down the way that at least
he was trained but they're not also
knowing that not all cops are trained
the same way so they all don't have the
same school of thought and then I know
and it's like during a time like this
where if there's already tension between
civilians and also the police officers
with the violent protests it increases
those tensions so like now if you're
already a stupid cop it makes you do
even more stupider [ __ ] like I'm like
you're not you're even more not looking
at civilians as people so it's just it's
just the horrible cop who killed George
Floyd and his partner the Asian cop they
both had a bunch of incidents against
them apparently and nobody did anything
like two things that like that were not
reported but that like they opened they
left the case open for so they can kind
of investigate out of like 18 that's my
thing is I have a problem with the whole
blue veil the whole like blue protective
blue yeah it's like a fraternal thing
yeah it's not right I think the problem
is like when we have bullies in each
community that go out and unleash their
aggression then what ends up happening
is like let's say even 80% of cops are
greater even ninety right but it only
takes even just 1% of aggressive [ __ ]
like that to represent the rest of them
and now everyone's like [ __ ] Poli
usually in the hood though where they
know that there's like they don't really
have a voice you know what I mean so
it's like who are you gonna whose whose
word are you're gonna take the person
that lives in the hood or the cop well
people don't even know that right down
our street at 7-eleven the police here
accidentally killed a team that there
was a robbery going down
then I mean this kind of [ __ ] happens
all the time and this is why I think
people don't know why there's violence
and rioting is because people don't they
feel helpless right they're like why are
you overreacting and all that whoa you
don't know that this is the only thing
that's publicized if you if you didn't
grow up in these kind of neighborhoods
you live in a bubble
our street right here there was a
burglary that was going down or like a
robbery that was going down the sheriff
came and then ended up happening was a
boy got scared inside the 7-eleven and
he ran and they thought he was the
burglar and then they shot him to death
the guys didn't get in trouble but there
was no like internal investigation they
just moved him out of the department
also protects book exactly and so the
community felt like there was no justice
that this kid got killed and on top of
that the cops didn't do anything so what
ended up happening was now the I guess
the Mexican Mafia or whatever they got
involved and as a community they started
shooting at cops and so because this is
what's gonna happen right because if the
right cop killed today yeah I read about
on the way in I think you I think was in
Texas yeah I mean and we're gonna have
more of these situations which I feel
like see when there's corruption and
people feel that the system is broken I
don't ever feel like violence is the way
but you got to also understand that it
becomes violent when people feel like
there's no choice or option and the
system fails them right so then when
there's people out there like a man like
there's better ways to handle this and
I'm like I think people try well dude
and they waited to like the Freddie gray
investigation they waited for the
results the results came back the cop
gets acquitted like it all goes away
and it happens it happens it happens and
I think the thing is like everyone from
our generation and younger we don't want
to inherit this kind of world right
because there's a lot of pain and people
that experienced even as recent as like
20 30 years ago I think there's been
segregation what is that the 60s no
that's 50 years ago right so uh wait am
i math thing right right now 70 okay
well anyways that doesn't matter the
point is the people that live through a
lot of pain like that they're still live
today this is what
generation young people don't know is
like you in and also if you grew up in a
bubble you think the world is a [ __ ]
dope ass place and America is great and
it is great because we went through so
much progress but you also have to
remember that there's a lot of people
that went through this pain as well so
when you sit down and you go like what
the [ __ ] is this why are you guys acting
crazy would like looting is not the way
and all that it's like that's not the
[ __ ] patient Oh bro yeah it's the
only way to make a statement it's a
cattle it's a what changing imagine if
this didn't happen like would he have
been tried would he have even been hot
like he wasn't arrested for a while for
three days yeah and he's only being
charged for third-degree to me it's not
the rear manslaughter and that's the
part of the thing - that's exactly part
of all of it because there was a guy who
was killed last year he was it was in
December 2019 same thing cop like put
his knee on his neck and the guy like
basically died on the scene but then
they're not able to prove that the cop
intended to murder this person yeah so
that's why they did the third degree
charge because they have a chance to
prove that like he didn't intentionally
do it but he still did it like that's
the kind of I think the problem here is
that now we weaponized race right and we
make it a white black thing or a police
versus people thing but in reality I
think it's a corruption thing even with
a mod case those guys they maybe they
would have gotten trouble if they didn't
have connections to [ __ ] district
yeah an addicted imaginary white guy is
just like out being vigilantes they
probably would have gotten in trouble
who knows I don't know but it's a
connections thing that I don't like same
what the [ __ ] you know just everything
in the world I think it's a connections
and corruption and power thing where
it's like if we don't really keep these
[ __ ] accountable then what ends up
happening is all this [ __ ] that
they're doing to the rest of us they
never get uncovered and then you know
it's gonna erupt we've all seen cops act
out
I seen a cop body slam somebody for
walking across the street and like for
NOFA I mean they were just told
like like hey Don don't walk across the
street right now and this person didn't
hear them and the gut cop does grab some
[ __ ] suplexes I'm going back like are
tripping
power tripping and you only do that if
you think you can get away with it if if
you were to threaten there
chins or anything that actually like
matters to them in long run but being
like yo if you actually if you have
certain amounts of if you have a
complaint against you or whatever you're
[ __ ] like your pensions gone like all
this stuff there's ways to there's
solutions to this stuff that nobody's
even talking about yet yeah
[Music]
[Music]